In what they walk he's asking what you want I wasn't here in 10 minutes
I shoot you in the face and then hang up dummy. He wants you here in 10 minutes, or he shoots me in the face
Was he surprised when they sound surprised. An American with the machine gun has taken over created banka
Banka
She's obviously got a muscle cramp or something in her banana everybody
We will let the ladies go when it's over in a moment 1 million u.s
dollars in a Mustang 302 like Steve McQueen had and boy
Disable the cameras is he good shooting have you done this before?
The girls have have they been harmed yes, why would they say that cops lie to get what they were
All of Sweden would like to know what is it like being stuck in there with those criminals it's not too bad
He let me call you didn't have to you and the others will survive and I can go home you're unbelievably brave
But you trust them more than we trust our police
If they read our help they need to show some respect as the police comes in released of shooting we will shoot fire
Okay, I got it he's like a child
Remember the Alamo wooooo